[Aplausos]
[Música]
la ciudad más cosmopolita la mejor
gastronomía el peso de la cultura todo
eso y mucho más es londres en un pasado
vídeo por supuesto aquí en visual
político fonseca ya nos contó cómo esta
mega polis ha logrado convertirse en una
de las ciudades que más crecen del mundo
que ha hecho que la capital británica
esté luchando con la mismísima nueva
york por conquistar el título que la
reconozca como la capital mundial de las
finanzas la capital del dinero
londres es otro mundo de hecho a día de
hoy ya es la cuarta capital que más
rápido está creciendo casi al mismo
nivel que dubai en este vídeo fonseca
nos habló mucho de migración de
servicios profesionales y sobre todo de
la cidh que viene a ser algo así como
otra ciudad un territorio autónomo hecho
por y para las finanzas en pleno corazón
de londres su estatus es tan particular
que como vimos cuenta incluso con sus
propias leyes su propia policía y sus
propios gobernantes podríamos decir que
la city es algo así como una especie de
vaticano donde la fe es en este caso el
dinero y los cardenales son los grandes
bancos sin embargo en 2016 se produjo
estoy convencido que lo recordáis bien
un acontecimiento que hizo temblar
literalmente los cimientos de este
modelo el 23 de junio de dicho año los
ciudad
del reino unido- votaron a favor de
abandonar la unión europea votaron a
favor del brasil la consecuencia más
inmediata se ha producido en el número
10 de downing street puesto que el
primer ministro david cameron ha
anunciado su dimisión tras la victoria
del break sit así que nos falta una
pregunta fundamental será capaz de
sobrevivir la cita al bressi y eso es
precisamente de lo que vamos a tratar de
responder en este vídeo pero antes que
nada
[Música]
cómo de importante es realmente la city
a la city se la conoce también como
square main la milla cuadrada porque
esto es precisamente lo que mide su
superficie si es un poquito más grande
que el vaticano pero muchísima más
pequeña que la gran manzana manhattan es
20 veces más grande vamos que en media
hora podemos recorrer la city de punta a
punta por el largo y también por el
ancho a pesar de ello no os equivoquéis
porque la city no es un juego de niños
de hecho es por volumen de transacciones
en el mayor centro financiero del mundo
que se dice pronto
para que os hagáis una idea en este
minúsculo espacio viven tan solo nueve
mil personas pero cada día van a
trabajar más de trescientos mil y están
presentes 250 bancos internacionales
pero queréis dos datos capaces de
ponernos los pelos de punta pues atentos
en la city se negocian cada día
productos financieros por valor de casi
2 millones de dólares la tercera parte
del total que se mueve en todo el mundo
en esta ciudad se gestiona atentos el 40
por ciento de todas las operaciones en
euros y también el 40 por ciento de todo
el mercado mundial de divisas es
impresionante
y claro todo este enorme negocio supone
miles de millones en comisiones y
también en impuestos la city hoy por hoy
es una auténtica mina de oro para el
gobierno de reino unido cada año le
genera al gobierno británico más de 80
mil millones de dólares y amigos el
dinero llama al dinero así que ahora
podemos entender por qué londres a pesar
de su poco agradable clima es una de las
ciudades con más millonarios del mundo
aquí es fácil encontrar a oligarcas
rusos jeques del petróleo miembros de la
realeza europea
nos vamos millonarios de todos los tipos
y colores visto todo esto es fácil
comprender porque con el presi ha
saltado todas las alarmas porque
veámoslo
la unión europea y el pasaporte
comunitario pertenecer a la unión
europea desde luego tiene muchas
ventajas una de ellas muy importante es
el llamado pasaporte financiero con el
los bancos que están en londres pueden
realizar operaciones en cualquier país
de la unión europea sin tener que sacar
licencias locales en cada uno de los
países es decir si un banco
internacional se instala en londres
puede operar en toda la unión europea y
además sus trabajadores pueden ir y
venir sin necesitar ninguna
documentación por ello cuando un banco
extranjero quiere hacer negocios en
europa se establecen en la city donde
además se beneficia de todas las
ventajas de esta ciudad y ojo porque no
sólo hablamos de menos regulaciones o
menos impuestos también de la capacidad
de hacer muchos más negocios gracias al
peso que londres tiene en las finanzas
internacionales
[Música]
esto es lo que explica que londres a
pesar de utilizar la libra esterlina sea
la capital del euro y claro es evidente
si reino unido abandona la unión europea
desaparecerán los más de 330.000
pasaportes financieros que esta ciudad
tiene registrados en este caso todos los
grandes bancos internacionales que
quisieran tendrían que abrir filiales en
alguno de los otros países de la unión
europea con todos los costes que ello
implica puede ser dublín puede ser
frankfurt puede ser
parís y puede ser madrid por ello
algunos de los bancos más grandes del
mundo como goldman sachs jp morgan o
bank of america se opusieron al presi y
también por esto en los últimos tiempos
están apareciendo noticias como estas
la city podría perder 30 mil empleos
directos por culpa del presi así que si
nos preguntan casi podríamos contestar
que hay que ser muy atrevidos para poner
en juego esta ruleta de la fortuna' nos
parece bueno pues la verdad no todo está
tan claro hay mucho que decir al
respecto y desde luego el futuro no está
para nada resuelto de hecho los mismos
pronósticos se hicieron cuando reino
unido- decidió pasar del euro y quedarse
con la libra veamos que ocurrió
[Música]
el euro un motor para latir cuando reino
unido decidió quedarse fuera del euro
prácticamente los mismos bancos y
también muchos expertos dijeron que la
cosa estaba clara la moneda común
suponía el final para la city no había
nada que hacer la suerte estaba echada
parís/madrid milán y sobre todo
frankfurt en la ciudad del poderoso
banco acepta europeo
serían sin lugar a dudas las nuevas
capitales financieras de europa pero lo
cierto es que se equivocaron un poquito
bueno a decir verdad se equivocaron
tanto que ocurrió todo lo contrario
dijeron que la city moriría porque el
reino unido no era parte del euro
dijeron que frankfurt sería el rey pero
nada de eso pasó
desde que apareció el euro no solo la
economía del reino unido ha crecido más
que la de la eurozona sino que la citi
ha incrementado muchísimo su tamaño y
por supuesto su diferencia respecto a
las ciudades que antes mencionados sólo
un dato hoy la city emplea un 50% más de
personas que en 1999 no está mal verdad
la moneda que compartimos 300 millones
de europeos está ya en circulación 12
países han iniciado la transición para
despedir a sus monedas nacionales y
utilizar solo el euro pero es que es más
ni una sola de las tres ciudades
europeas con el sector financiero más
importante está en un país de la unión
europea hablamos de londres
-claro está- y turín y génova en suiza-
frankfurt es la cuarta y para ser justos
no todo el crecimiento de la city ha
sido gracias a las operaciones en la
unión europea atentos al siguiente
gráfico en él vemos cómo ha evolucionado
el negocio internacional del reino
unido- dentro y fuera de la unión
europea
vamos que la unión europea' cada vez es
menos importante para el reino unido- y
para la city llegados a este punto puede
que las cosas ya no nos parezcan tan
obvias verdad pues bien ahora nos queda
ver cómo puede explotar la city el presi
para no sólo sobrevivir sino incluso
quién sabe poder seguir creciendo una
ciudad por y para las finanzas el
pasaporte financiero es importante pero
no tanto como se cuenta al fin y al cabo
un banco puede seguir dirigiendo sus
operaciones desde la city y abrir una
filial en cualquier país de la unión
europea para seguir operando con el
pasaporte a través de además veremos si
finalmente lo pierden es verdad que la
europea parece dispuesta a imponerle al
reino unido- un coste de salida elevado
para dar miedo y prevenir que otros
países sigan el camino pero amigos las
negociaciones para el versito acaban de
empezar y desde luego los británicos
tienen armas suficientes para presionar
por un buen acuerdo por ejemplo 500 mil
millones de comercio anual con un
balance muy favorable para el resto del
hombre
pero aún con todo hay algo mucho más
importante lo que podemos llamar el
software financiero es decir toda la
cantidad de servicios profesionales que
están concentrados en la ciudad
financiera el tamaño del propio mercado
la regulación existente e incluso cosas
como el idioma las oficinas disponibles
o los propios colegios y aquí londres
arras a los grandes despachos de
abogados las grandes firmas de
valoración de empresas y claro como
muchos partidarios del ver si defienden
si la city no tuviese que cumplir las
normas de la unión europea podría
desarrollar un marco fiscal y
regulatorio aún mucho más atractivo para
el sector financiero que compensaría y
con creces el tema del pasaporte es
verdad no está claro que lo vayan a
hacer y desde luego los riesgos son
muchos pero sorprendentemente si algo
parece tener claro en la city es que
nueva york singapur o hong kong son
adversarios más temibles entre otras
cosas porque están en las zonas del
mundo que más crecen así que amigos
todos aquellos que han empezado la
carrera por repartirse las joyas de la
corona' puede que se lleven un chasco yo
no tengo ninguna duda señoría de qué
la comunidad de madrid es la mejor
alternativa para todas esas empresas y
por eso precisamente el nombre de
nuestra candidatura no podría ser otro
que piensen en madrid sin madrid
muchísimas gracias bueno y qué piensas
tú que es que podrás sobrevivir la city
fuera de la unión europea
crees que ciudades como madrid podrán
arrebatarle el negocio al todopoderoso
corazón de londres espero vuestros
comentarios y no os olvidéis de darle a
like si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante y queréis que sigamos
hablando de finanzas un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]